à quel moment pollue ton le plus dans
notre quotidien quand on prend notre
voiture on dégage en moyenne 20% de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre quand
on mange de la viande 9% quand on prend
l'avion 4%
et quand on achète des vêtements 1% mais
au dessus de tout cela il y à bien plus
polluants notre maison entre le
chauffage la construction et
l'électroménager c'est 25% de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
au départ du château d'if une course en
pleine mer un parcours de 5 km mais au
bout de 200 mètres seulement les
sauveteurs en mer doivent intervenir
auprès des nageurs tout à coup et sont
mis à crier à hurler il s'est épris
d'art et bano méduses
moi je me suis fait piquer cinq fois on
a tous nagé comme on pouvait dans tous
les sens c'était ambiance titanic
c'était l'apocalypse ou est arrivé sur
le sable il faut stopper l'inflammation
d'une manière un peu surprenante maître
de la mousse à raser 3 4 minutes et
après gratter les petites tentacules
avec une carte de crédit une carte
vitale tu penses que ta langue c'est
pour faire plaisir parce que je suis
très mais très difficile en fait tu
manges pas ce que tu as fait qu'il ne
mange pas parce que je suis végétarien
je mange que du blanc tous les c'est
tout ce que je mange maryvonne on n'a
pas très bien compris là ça ça m'a
détendu un restaurateur mais des glaces
pour chiens à sa carte dans le bas à
regarder comme vous êtes tous contents
mais oui ça c'est dépendants et ben je
vais vous donner la
glace composé de foie de volaille jus de
veau et fumet de poisson des parfums
pour plaire aux chiens je n'ai jamais
voté une croquette mais c'est pas tout à
fait végétarienne et sexy j'ai vraiment
voulu être sympathique avec maryvonne
mais quand on est végétarien
mange pas dupe l'ampoulé le bloc c'est
pas de la viande c'est une volaille déjà
dit non c'est pas la vo
bonjour j'ai pas votre nom marcel parent
dont marcel marcel qu'est ce que vous
faites dans la vie si une émission de
retraités de la poste de facteur
d'accord dont vous avez vous êtes tout
d'un coup vous êtes venu vendre israël
parce que c'est un métier quand même ah
oui non mais ça je confirme
irez-vous patrick oui il faut pas bouger
les lèvres à cantonner dans cette
affaire je m'y connais pas regardez cap
des éditeurs
et regardez up aaa
c'est le rêve
c'est génial 20
je la veux pas lui connais pas beaucoup
mais je pense que le but du ventriloque
mais qu'on voit pas
bougé présidence et vous faites par les
uns bout à bout de moquette gauvin et
des gens qui mais il est super sympa il
alors là vraiment on termine par une
banale une bataille qui ressemble un peu
à celle de david contre goliath
regardez ça se passe en chine un homme a
lancé des feux d'artifice contre une
pelleteuse qui étaient venus pour
détruire sa maison sous les tirs vous
allez le voir la pelle mécanique recul
tant qu'entraîneur qu'en mer et elle se
retourne littéralement
j'ai peur que ce pauvre en mai des
soucis que des hommes pour diriger les
pays du g7 donc ils ont mis en place
donc cette photo ap ils ont mis en place
la photo des femmes à côté et moi si
j'étais une femme je refuserai de faire
la photo des femmes voilà
voilà les femmes dans quelles sont les
images des femmes qui est donnée alors
c'est tout ma vie des requins journal ce
qui est mis ce petit truite jeu c'est
lui à qui revient les hommes travaillent
les femmes se divertissent que wallace
comme l'éclat
les divertir quoi de mieux qu'une belle
fête pour rassembler tout un peuple
depuis le premier bal du 14 juillet la
république nous a invités à la fête dans
un même élan
elle l'a encadré surveiller et parfois
même interdite je pense que que ce soit
le confinement ou les guerres quelle que
soit la population sur la pêche de
danser elle explosera à un moment donné